أهلاً بكم مجدداً في الحوسبة الكمومية في التطبيق العملي. هذه الحلقة ستركز على الخطوة الأولى والأكثر تحدياً غالباً
في تعريف برنامج كمومي: تعيين مشكلة عامة على circuit يمكن تشغيلها على حاسوب
كمومي. هذه الخطوة تصف كيف يمكن للمستخدم الذي يبدأ بمشكلة حسابية
معينة ترجمتها بحيث يفهمها الحاسوب الكمومي.
في دروس سابقة من هذه السلسلة الدرسين الثاني والثالث ناقشنا أن مرحلة التعيين هي الخطوة الأولى من
أربع في إطار عمل أنماط Qiskit. من تلك الدروس قد تتذكرون أن هدفنا كان ترجمة
أو إعادة كتابة مشكلة حسابية إلى دالة تكلفة أو قيمة متوقعة
يمكننا تقييمها باستخدام حاسوب كمومي.
في الدرس الثالث ناقشنا مثالاً محدداً مع Max Cut وهي مشكلة
صعبة حسابياً وشائعة في التحسين التوافقي.
في ذلك المثال مررنا بعدة خطوات لتحويل الرسم البياني الأولي إلى مشكلة أصلية للكم.
حولنا مشكلة إيجاد العدد الأقصى من القطوع في الرسم البياني إلى دالة تكلفة ثم أعدنا كتابة دالة
التكلفة كهاملتوني وحضرنا حالة كمومية تجريبية حالتها الأرضية
تتوافق مع القطع الأقصى. أخيراً بنينا circuit كمومية تمثل الحالة الكمومية التجريبية
المطلوبة ثم أضفنا البوابات المحددة للسماح للحالة بالتطور عبر الزمن. هذا التسلسل من الخطوات هو ما
نسميه التعيين. وعلى مستوى عالٍ الإجراء عام للعديد من التطبيقات الأخرى مثل الكيمياء الكمومية
والمحاكاة الكمومية. الآن لا مفر من حقيقة أن التعيين يمكن أن يكون صعباً. لا توجد
استراتيجية واحدة تناسب كل مشكلة لذا يمكن أن يكون مخيفاً. اليوم سأسلط الضوء على
بعض الأمثلة التمثيلية لمشاكل مختلفة وأصف كيف تم تعيينها في كل حالة. سألخص بسرعة
ما تعلمناه عن مشاكل الرسوم البيانية كتلك المستخدمة في Max Cut وأقضي بقية الدرس في التركيز
على كيفية تعيين مشاكل تظهر في الطبيعة مثل مشاكل البنية الجزيئية في الأحياء والبنية
الإلكترونية في الكيمياء ومحاكاة نظريات الحقل الكمومي في فيزياء الطاقات العالية.
لكن قبل أن نقضي معظم وقتنا في هذه الحلقة في النظر لمشاكل مثال من الأدبيات العلمية أريد أن أعطيكم
نظرة عالية المستوى على الأشياء الرئيسية التي نريد إنجازها ومراعاتها عند تعيين مشكلة. هناك
بعض الأشياء التي يجب مراعاتها لأي نوع من المشاكل الحسابية التي ستحتاج لترجمتها إلى circuit كمومية.
أولاً قد تحتاجون لتبسيط المشكلة لجعلها ممكنة. هذا شيء شائع في معظم التخصصات
العلمية وليس فريداً للحوسبة الكمومية. إذا سمعتم يوماً بتعبير "افترض بقرة
كروية" فهو يشير لحقيقة أنه غالباً من الصعب وصف نظام بالضبط كما يظهر. لكن
بدلاً من ذلك يمكننا إجراء تبسيطات معقولة تظل تقود لحلول مفيدة.
بعض أمثلة كيف يمكننا فعل ذلك في الحوسبة الكمومية هي تحديد الحجم أو عمق الـ circuit باختيار
أنساتز فعال للعتاد أو اقتطاع تطورات زمنية معقدة أو إهمال
حدود الهاملتوني التي تساهم قليلاً في الطاقة النهائية لحالة كمومية.
النقطة التالية هي أنكم ستحتاجون للتفكير في كتابة المشكلة بطريقة يمكن للحاسوب الكمومي فهمها.
غالباً يتضمن ذلك طرح هذه الأسئلة الثلاثة. أولاً ماذا ستمثل الـ qubit
في هذا النموذج؟ ثانياً هل مشكلتنا مستمرة؟ بما أن الحواسيب الكمومية رقمية ستحتاجون
لإيجاد طريقة لتقسيم المشكلة. وثالثاً وأخيراً هل تتوافق طوبولوجيا المشكلة مع طوبولوجيا
العتاد؟ إذا نعم فهذا رائع. لكن إذا لا فقد نحتاج لتنفيذ بعض الحيل لجعلها تعمل. لنتناول
هذا السؤال الأول. ما أعتقد أنه في صميم كل صعوبات فهم التعيين خاصة
كمفهوم جديد: ماذا يمكن أن يمثل الـ qubit؟
الـ qubit يمكن استخدامها لتمثيل أشياء كثيرة. الأول والأبسط في رأيي هو عقدة على رسم بياني. الرسوم البيانية
تُستخدم لإظهار الاتصالية في أنواع مختلفة كثيرة من المشاكل الرياضية. والعقد هي عنصر أساسي يمثل نقطة
أو كيان ضمن شبكة. حسب ما تمثله الشبكة بأكملها يمكن أن تكون مدينة أو شخصاً أو
مغناطيساً حديدياً في شبكة. الـ qubit يمكن أيضاً استخدامها لتمثيل البوزونات والفرميونات. رغم أنني سأحذر هنا
أن qubit واحد لا يساوي بالضبط بوزوناً واحداً أو فرميوناً واحداً. الأمر
أصعب قليلاً من ذلك وسأتناوله بعد قليل لكن بشكل عام سلسلة من اللفات التي تتبع إحصائيات معينة هي
شيء يمكن ترجمته بسهولة إلى معمارية qubit.
الآن ندخل في أمثلة أكثر تعقيداً. لهذه النماذج لم يعد من المنطقي التحدث
بدلالة qubit واحد.
بدلاً من ذلك نحتاج لمجموعات منها لتكوين شيء فيزيائي. مثلاً مجموعة
من الـ qubit هنا ممثلة على طوبولوجيا سداسية ثقيلة يمكن استخدامها لتمثيل المواقع الهندسية للأحماض
الأمينية أو سلاسل البوليمر. مثال آخر هو محاكاة تشتت الهادرونات
في نماذج فيزياء الطاقات العالية والتي يمكن القيام بها بمحاكاة التطور الزمني لحزمة موجة هادرونية. في هذه الحالة
يمكن استخدام سجل من الـ qubit لترميز حالات مختلفة لحقل كمومي. حالة الفراغ لذلك الحقل أو
حزمة موجة تنتشر فوق هذا الفراغ.
أريد أيضاً أن ألاحظ أن تعيين المشكلة على حاسوب كمومي له خطوات مميزة وهي: أولاً تعيين
الحالات على الـ qubit والدوائر وثانياً تعيين دالة التكلفة أو القيمة المتوقعة
للمرصودات والمشغلات الكمومية. سنرى كيف تُعالج هذه في أمثلة محددة. لكن عند
هذه النقطة تحدثنا بشكل مجرد بما فيه الكفاية عن التحدي أمامنا.
لنلقِ نظرة على هذه الأمثلة الآن بالتفصيل.
لنبدأ بمثالنا الأول. في رأيي أحد أسهل مشاكل التعيين هي تلك التي غطيناها
بالفعل بشيء من العمق وهي مثال Max Cut. في تلك المشكلة كان التعيين سهلاً نسبياً لأن qubit واحد
يساوي عقدة واحدة على الرسم البياني. استخدام العقد على رسم بياني بديهي جداً وهذا
حظ جيد لأنه يتوافق مع تطبيقات كثيرة. في كثير من الأحيان عندما تريدون نمذجة شيء يتوافق مع
سلسلة من العقد المتصلة إذا كانت التجميعات ثنائية مثل صفر أو واحد أو مضمنة وغير مضمنة في
مجموعة يمكنكم ببساطة وطبيعية تعيين هذه العقد على بتات أو qubit.
في هذا المثال وحتى في ذلك الذي وسعناه إلى 100 qubit في الحلقة 3 اتصالية الرسم البياني
كانت تطابق بالفعل طوبولوجيا عتادنا فائق التوصيل. لذا لم نحتج للقلق بشأن ذلك أيضاً. لكن هذا ليس دائماً الحال.
وإذا كان لديكم رسم بياني أكثر تعقيداً أو اتصالاً من الأمثلة التي سلطنا الضوء عليها حتى الآن فستحتاجون
لتنفيذ بوابات تبديل. لكن هذا يُعالج فعلياً في الخطوة الثانية من أنماط Qiskit المعنية
بالنقل. الجزء الآخر من مشكلة Max Cut الذي يجعلها عملية جداً هو أننا
نعرف بالفعل كيفية التعبير عن دالة التكلفة كهاملتوني باستخدام صيغة QUBO.
تذكروا أنه في الحوسبة الكمومية والخوارزميات الكمومية التباينية فإن هاملتوني دالة التكلفة هو دالة
تُشفر الحل الأمثل للمشكلة في الحالة الأرضية للهاملتوني.
لبناء هاملتوني التكلفة تمكنا من استخدام فئة SparsePauliOp في Qiskit لتحديد
اتصالية الرسم البياني ومرحلة التعيين للمشغلات الكمومية تمت. والـ circuit الكمومية كانت
ببساطة أنساتز QAOA. إذا لم يبدُ هذا مألوفاً يرجى العودة ومشاهدة الحلقة 3 حيث نستعرض
هذا بتفصيل أكبر بكثير. الآن لنرفع الصعوبة قليلاً. بعد ذلك سننظر
في مثال من ورقة بعنوان "خوارزمية كمومية فعالة الموارد لطي البروتينات" كتبتها
IBM بالتعاون مع جامعة New South Wales. بعض الخلفية في الكيمياء الحيوية: البروتينات هي
جزيئات كبيرة تتكون من سلاسل طويلة من الأحماض الأمينية. هذه السلاسل الطويلة تنطوي
في بنى معقدة تؤدي مجموعة واسعة من الوظائف البيولوجية.
تحديد بنية البروتين في الفضاء ثلاثي الأبعاد وفهم العلاقات بين
البنية والوظيفة هما من أصعب المشاكل في الكيمياء الحيوية اليوم.
البروتينات تنطوي في بنى مفيدة بسبب التفاعلات بين الأحماض الأمينية نفسها.
مع لف البنية وطيها قد ينتهي المطاف بأحماض أمينية بعيدة عن بعضها في السلسلة
بجوار بعضها وقد تتفاعل بقوة. نحتاج للحصول على هاملتوني يصف جميع هذه التفاعلات بين الأحماض
الأمينية إذا أردنا التنبؤ بأي بنية نهائية ستُقلل الطاقة. هنا سنركز على سلاسل الأحماض الأمينية و
كيف يمكن نمذجتها على حاسوب كمومي ثم كيف يمكننا الحصول على المسافات بين الأحماض الأمينية
لحساب طاقات التفاعل.
بهذا نكون قد جمعنا فعلاً جميع المساهمات الضرورية للهاملتوني من أجل محاكاته
على حاسوب كمومي. في البروتينات الحقيقية يمكن للأحماض الأمينية أن تشغل متصلاً من المواقع الممكنة.
لكننا سنستخدم تبسيطاً هنا ونقيدها بنموذج شبكة حيث كل حمض أميني
يشغل نقطة على شبكة. هنا استخدم المؤلفون شبكة رباعية الأوجه.
ملاحظة سريعة هنا: نحن نُرمّز اتجاه الحواف وليس العقد نفسها كما في مشكلة Max Cut.
كل qubit يمثل مساراً محتملاً بخطوة واحدة على الشبكة الرباعية. لاحظوا أن المواقع المتجاورة
وُسمت في هذا المخطط بـ A أو B بسبب اتجاهاتها المختلفة في الشبكة.
سلسلة البروتين تُمثل كسلسلة من المنعطفات أو الاتجاهات على هذه
الشبكة. كل منعطف بين الأحماض الأمينية يمكن أن يكون في أحد أربعة اتجاهات
المقابلة لحواف رباعي الأوجه.
هذه المنعطفات الأربعة الممكنة تُرمّز باستخدام أربعة qubit.
يبدو هذا صعباً بعض الشيء. لننظر لهذا المثال بمزيد من التعمق.
لنضع حمضنا الأميني الأول على هذه النقطة في الشبكة الرباعية. الاتجاه إلى الحمض
الأميني الأول نحو الثاني تعسفي لأن النظام يمكن دائماً تدويره ليجعل تلك الحافة تشير
بأي اتجاه نريد. لنضع حمضنا الأميني الثاني هنا. ليس من السهل
رؤيته لكن المسار من الثاني إلى الثالث هو فعلاً تعسفي أيضاً. جميع الخيارات الثلاثة ستؤدي
إلى وجود حافتين بزاوية حوالي 109.5 درجة
بينهما. اختيار هذه الحافة الثانية ببساطة يحدد توجه البروتين في الفضاء. لذا بدون فقدان
أي عمومية يمكننا اختيار المنعطفات الأولى لتكون 0 0 1 و 0 0 1
0. مع هذه التبسيطات تكوين سلسلة الأحماض الأمينية يُعطى ببساطة بهذا التعبير.
حتى الآن عيّنا حواف رباعي الأوجه على qubit والـ circuit الكمومية ستكون أنساتز. الآن نحتاج
للتفكير في كيفية ترميز طاقة المشكلة في هاملتوني بحيث تعطينا حالته الأرضية نمط
الطي الأمثل. لأي تكوين معين ستكون هناك طاقة مرتبطة بسبب
التفاعلات بين الأحماض الأمينية نفسها. هذه التفاعلات أقوى عندما يكون الحمضان الأمينيان
قريبين من بعضهما. بوضوح الأحماض الأمينية المتجاورة في العمود الفقري للسلسلة ستتفاعل دائماً
مع بعضها. لكن لأن البروتين يمكن أن يلتف وينطوي فإن أزواج أحماض أمينية أخرى
يمكن أن تتفاعل أيضاً. الأحماض الأمينية 10 و 20 مثلاً قد ينتهي بها المطاف على
مواقع متجاورة بعد انطواء البروتين. الأحماض الأمينية التي ينتهي بها المطاف قريبة من بعضها لها تفاعلات
أقوى وتدفع عملية الانطواء لكنها لا تملك بالضرورة مؤشرات قريبة من بعضها
البعض. لذا نحتاج لصيغة تصف المسافة D بين الأحماض الأمينية i و
j باستخدام المعلومات المُرمّزة على qubit التكوين. بهذه الطريقة يمكننا
استخدام مسافة الفصل لتحديد مدى قوة تفاعلها. هذا معقد بعض الشيء
لكن تحملوا معي لأنها حيلة أنيقة. أولاً لنقدم دالة f أسفل a من i التي تشير إلى ما إذا كان أو
لا يُستخدم الضلع a للانعطاف عند الحمض الأميني i. هنا يمكن أن يأخذ a أي
من الاتجاهات الأربعة الممكنة في ضوء ترميز التكوين أعلاه. يمكننا كتابة هذه الدوال ثم
يمكننا تعريف الفرق في عدد الانعطافات المُسمّاة a على شبكتي A وB من
الفهرس I إلى الفهرس J بـ delta N. لماذا نفعل ذلك؟ حسناً، اتضح أن
الشبكة الرباعية الأوجه لها خاصية مفيدة جداً. دعونا نركز على هذا الحمض الأميني هنا. لا يهم أي واحد
هو، لكن دعونا نسميه الحمض الأميني E. نريد أن نعرف كم يبعد الحمض الأميني j. وكل ما لدينا
هو الأضلاع التي يمشي عليها العمود الفقري. بدءاً من I لاحظ أن خطوة
من المركز على طول نوع ضلع معين نسميه a من موقع الشبكة a
هي عكس تماماً ويتم إلغاؤها بخطوة على طول الضلع a من مواقع
الشبكة b. إذن خطوات متعددة على طول الضلع A من أي موقع على شبكة A تحرك
العمود الفقري بعيداً عن الحمض الأميني E وخطوات على طول نوع الضلع A من مواقع B
تعيدك. إذن المسافة بين حمضين أمينيين I وJ على طول نوع الضلع
الذي سنسميه A تعتمد على الفرق بين الخطوات على أضلاع A
من مواقع A ومواقع B. بما أن A وB يتناوبان بالضرورة في
العمود الفقري للبروتين، فهذا يُلتقط بحد سالب واحد أُس K. وهذا المنطق ينطبق على أنواع الأضلاع الأخرى
أيضاً. إذن المسافة بين الأحماض الأمينية بخطوات الشبكة الرباعية الأوجه يمكن حسابها في النهاية بهذا
التعبير. لكن كيف نحصل على الهاملتونيان من هذه المعادلة الطويلة للمسافة الكلية بين الأحماض الأمينية؟ هناك
في الواقع تطابق واحد لواحد بين هذه المسافات بخطوات الشبكة الرباعية الأوجه والمسافة
الإقليدية. ويمكنك أن ترى أنني حسبت بعض التعبيرات لكم مسبقاً.
يمكن استخدام هذه المسافات في حساب طاقة التكوين الخاص بك.
حسب هدفك، قد تحدد مسافة قطع يُعتبر تحتها الزوج متفاعلاً
أو قد تفعل شيئاً أكثر تعقيداً. قد لا يكون واضحاً، لكننا في الواقع انتهينا من مرحلة الربط
بفعل ذلك. حالات الـ qubit تشير إلى الانعطاف، ومجموعة الانعطافات تحدد
المسافة بين أي زوج من الأحماض الأمينية. أزواج الأنواع المختلفة من الأحماض
الأمينية لها تفاعلات مختلفة، بعضها جاذبة وبعضها طاردة. إذا كنت تستخدم التكوين والمسافة
فقط لتحديد ما إذا كانت تفاعلات الأحماض الأمينية المعروفة مفعّلة أو معطّلة،
فإن شدة هذه التفاعلات معروفة جيداً. ليس من قِبلي، لكن يمكنك البحث عنها في جدول مثل هذا. إذن باختصار، في
هذا المثال، تُستخدم الـ qubit لتحديد المواقع على شبكة تشكل معاً سلسلة من الأحماض الأمينية.
ومن خلال محاكاة كيفية انحنائها وطيّها، يمكننا أن نأمل في إيجاد نتائج أفضل في البحث الطبي. الآن،
تخطينا كيفية حساب بعض حدود هذا الهاملتونيان لأنها كانت محددة جداً لهذه المسألة. بينما تعريف
الاتجاهات على شبكة يمكن تطبيقه بشكل أعم.
الآن بمجرد أن يكون لديك هاملتونيان عام، ستحتاج دائماً إلى ترجمته إلى مؤثرات باولي التي
هي أصلية في الحاسوب الكمي. هذا ما سنناقشه بعد ذلك.
دعونا نستمر. الآن دعونا نستكشف كيفية ترجمة نظام من الجسيمات دون الذرية إلى مؤثرات باولي. الجسيمات دون
الذرية تنقسم إلى فئتين. البوزونات والفرميونات. البوزونات
مثل الفوتونات أو هيغز تخضع لمجموعة معينة من القواعد الإحصائية والفرميونات مثل الإلكترونات أو النيوترينوات تخضع لمجموعة أخرى.
الفرق الأساسي بينهما هو أن البوزونات يُسمح لها بشغل نفس الحالة. لا يوجد حد لعدد
البوزونات التي يمكن أن تكون في الحالة الأرضية أو أي حالة مثارة أخرى. الفرميونات من ناحية أخرى أنانية. تتطلب أن
يكون لكل جسيم حالته الكمية الخاصة. البوزونات لها أيضاً لف مغزلي صحيح بينما الفرميونات لها لف مغزلي نصف صحيح
مثل الإلكترون ذو اللف المغزلي 1/2 أو جسيمات أكثر غرابة بلف مغزلي ثلاثة أنصاف. لكي
نصف نظاماً من الجسيمات، نحتاج وصفاً لطاقتها. دعونا نركز على الفرميونات. يمكننا البدء بـ
الهاملتونيان المكتوب بما نسميه مؤثرات C. هذه في الأساس كائنات رياضية
تقابل إنشاء أو إفناء فرميون من حالة في النظام.
تُكتب هذه عادة بصيغة fi خنجر وfi وبترميز نسميه التكميم
الثاني. الآن fi خنجر هو المؤثر الذي ينشئ فرميوناً في الحالة i. وfi هو
المؤثر الذي يدمر فرميوناً في الحالة i. لكن تذكر أن الحواسيب الكمية تعمل عادة بأساس الـ qubit
مع قواعد محددة لتمثيل الأنظمة الفرميونية. إنها لا تعمل بطبيعتها بلغة
المؤثرات الفرميونية. لسد هذه الفجوة، نحتاج إلى ربط ترميز التكميم الثاني بمؤثرات باولي التي
تقابل بشكل طبيعي البوابات الكمية.
هناك عدة تحويلات من هذا النوع للفرميونات. خيار شائع هو تحويل Jordan-Wigner.
وتحويلات Bravyi-Kitaev وParity هي أحدث للترميزات الفرميونية.
العمليات البوزونية من ناحية أخرى يمكن تحويلها باستخدام تحويل Holstein-Primakoff أو مباشرة
بربط حالات Fock بأساس فرعي من الأنماط البوزونية المتاحة.
وهناك خيارات أخرى للبوزونات أيضاً. ترميزات أخرى يتم البحث فيها بنشاط. لكن في الوقت الحالي، سنركز
فقط على تحويل Jordan-Wigner.
فلماذا لا نخصص qubit واحد لتمثيل كل إلكترون؟ حسناً، لا نستطيع.
الـ qubit قابلة للتمييز والإلكترونات ليست كذلك. مثلاً، يمكننا بسهولة تسمية وتحديد الـ qubit الفردية على
أي جهاز، لكن عدم قابلية تمييز الإلكترونات يعني أننا لا نستطيع تسميتها أبداً. نحتاج في الواقع إلى تسمية
المؤثرات بدلاً من ذلك حسب المدارات المشغولة مثل 1s و2s و2p
بدلاً من إلكترونات محددة. وبالتالي نحتاج في الواقع إلى تسمية المؤثرات حسب المدارات المشغولة مثل 1s
و2s و2p بدلاً من تسمية إلكترونات محددة. إذن كل qubit يلعب
تقريباً دور مدار في الجزيء يكون إما مشغولاً أو غير مشغول.
لكن كيفية القيام بذلك في الواقع أكثر تعقيداً بقليل. والآن نقدم شيئاً يُسمى ربط Jordan-Wigner لتتبع
عدم التماثل وضمان أن الإحصائيات الصحيحة للنظام الفرميوني الكلي يتم الالتزام بها. ربط Jordan-
Wigner بسيط مفاهيمياً بسبب التطابق واحد لواحد بين المدارات والـ qubit. هناك
عمليات ربط أخرى تحقق هدفاً مشابهاً بما في ذلك ربط التكافؤ.
حساب تكافؤ حالة يتطلب النظر في عدة qubit. في ربط التكافؤ وبعض العمليات الأخرى،
تفسير أن qubit واحد يقابل مداراً واحداً لا ينطبق.
الآن دعونا نمشي معاً على مثال بسيط جداً للتأكد من أننا فهمنا هذا التحويل.
لنقل أننا نريد حساب تفاعل الـ qubit الواحد f خنجر f. نبدأ بتعويض تعريفاتنا لمؤثرات
الرفع والخفض. ثم يمكننا تجميع الحدود مع إخراج مصفوفة الوحدة I والـ 1/4.
كما نرى، نحصل على حدود ستكون مألوفة لمن يتعامل مع علاقات التبديل. هذا الحد هنا في
القوسين ليس سوى i مضروباً في مبدّل x وy. ولا
تنسَ الوحدة التي أخرجناها.
الآن تذكر أن هذه مجرد مصفوفات باولي. وبالتالي المبدّل معروف جيداً. مبدّل x وy بهذا
الترتيب بسيط. إنه 2iz. تأكد من عدم فقدان الإشارات السالبة وستحصل على هذا كنتيجة
نهائية. في النهاية، نجحنا في إعادة كتابة تعبير فرميوني بدلالة
مؤثرات باولي التي سيتمكن حاسوبنا الكمي من فهمها.
دعونا نناقش بسرعة كيف يمكننا تطبيق ربط Jordan-Wigner في Qiskit لأنه رغم أنني أعتقد أنه
مهم أن تفهم كيف يعمل الربط والتحويلات المشابهة وتراه محلولاً مرة واحدة على الأقل،
لن ترغب في القيام بكل هذا العمل يدوياً في كل مرة.
خاصة للأنظمة الكبيرة بشكل خاص، يمكننا استخدام دالة sparse poly op في Qiskit لإنشاء
عمليات باولي المرتبطة بسهولة من عملية ربط. تطبيق غير
مُحسَّن سيستخدم حلقات متداخلة ويأخذ حوالي 20 سطراً من الكود.
سأضع رابط الكود هنا لتستكشفوه جميعاً. لكن على مستوى عالٍ، الخطوات كالتالي.
أولاً، استخدم دالة sparse poly ops from list لإنشاء مؤثر وحدة
يقابل حجم فضاء المعاملات المراد ربطه. ثانياً، باتباع تعريف مؤثرات الإنشاء
والإفناء الموضحة سابقاً، استخدم دالة sparse poly ops from list لتعريف عمليات باولي x وy وz.
هذا سيربط مؤثرات الإنشاء والإفناء الفرميونية بمؤثرات اللف المغزلي للـ qubit مع ترميز أعداد الإشغال الفرميونية
في الأساس الحسابي للـ qubit وثالثاً توليد
الهاملتونيان المطلوب في أساس باولي بتطبيق المؤثرات أعلاه على المدارات المعنية. هذا يقابل عادة
إنشاء مصفوفة وحدة تمثل النواة أي المدارات غير المتفاعلة ثم تطبيق مؤثرات الإنشاء
والإفناء على الفضاء الفعال بأوزان تقابل تفاصيل المسألة المطروحة. كما
ذكرت، هذا مجرد تحليل عالي المستوى. الكود ليس معقداً جداً، ويجب أن
تشعر الآن بالثقة في تكييفه لمسائل أخرى تهمك.
الآن بعد أن فهمنا ربط Jordan-Wigner بالكامل، دعونا نراه عملياً في إعداد أكثر تعقيداً.
قد تتذكرون هذه الورقة البحثية من حلقة سابقة أيضاً عن ديناميكيات الهادرونات. لن أخوض في الورقة مرة أخرى بالتفصيل، لكن يرجى مراجعة
الحلقة السابقة إن فاتتكم وأنتم فضوليون. في هذا المثال، يُستخدم ربط Jordan-Wigner للتعبير عن
هاملتونيان مواقع الشبكة ذات L موقع لنموذج Schwinger في غياب المجال الكهربائي. هنا،
من الصعب جداً تحديد ما يمثله qubit واحد في هذا النموذج لأنه فقط
مجموعة الـ qubit معاً هي التي تصنع شيئاً فيزيائياً. في هذا السياق، حزمة موجية. بدلاً من ذلك، يمكنك تقريباً
التفكير في الـ qubit كقطع متقطعة من الفضاء حيث L هنا هو حجم الشبكة الذي يتكون كل عنصر أو
خلية وحدة فيه من qubit اثنين. المؤثرات الفرميونية التي رأيناها في الشريحة السابقة تصف سعة
دالة الموجة على موقع معين.
إذن الهاملتونيان لدينا يحتوي على مؤثرات الرفع والخفض الفرميونية هذه. لكن لتطبيق مثل هذا
الهاملتونيان على حاسوب كمي، سنحتاج للتعبير عنه بدلالة مؤثرات اللف المغزلي، وليس المؤثرات الفرميونية.
إذن نستخدم تحويل Jordan-Wigner. بعد تطبيق تحويل Jordan-Wigner، يصبح
الهاملتونيان الجديد هذه المعادلة في أسفل الشريحة حيث سيغما زائد هو مؤثر باولي X + iY وسيغما
ناقص هو X - iY. بمجرد أن يكون لدينا هاملتونيان مكتوب بهذا الشكل،
فإن الجزء الصعب من مرحلة الربط انتهى ويمكن كتابته بسهولة كـ circuit بمؤثرات باولي.
باختصار، ناقشنا أربعة أمثلة على كيفية استخدام تقنيات الربط المحددة مؤخراً في
مجال الحوسبة الكمية. بدءاً من الأبسط وصولاً إلى تطبيق تحويل Jordan-Wigner على
ديناميكيات الهادرونات. أدرك أن هذا كثير. هذه المادة كانت تقنية جداً
وإذا لم تكن قد رأيتها من قبل، يمكن أن تكون مخيفة جداً. الخبر السار هو أنني أعدكم أنها تصبح أسهل
وأكثر ألفة كلما قضيتم وقتاً أطول في التمرين. وهذا حقاً بيت القصيد ولماذا سميت السلسلة
بأكملها الحوسبة الكمية في التطبيق.
هذا ليس شيئاً يمكن لأي شخص أن يلتقطه ويبدأ به من البداية. يتطلب بعض الدراسة، وبعض
حك الرأس، وربما بعض الأوقات المحبطة. لكنني أشجعكم جميعاً على تقبّل عدم الراحة
واستكشاف الأسئلة التي تنشأ فعلاً وأنتم تواصلون لأن هذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة للتعلم حقاً. شكراً
للمشاهدة. كانت هذه الحلقة 5 من الحوسبة الكمية في التطبيق. في المرة القادمة سنستكشف كيفية محاكاة
هاملتونيان من الصفر. نراكم قريباً.